hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
covid19 a clinical lab
response to a pandemic i'm susie valdez
of labyrinths and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you
by via soren inc and dsor molecular
to learn more visit molecular dot
theosorin.com
backslash u.s backslash kovid19
backslash
so let's get started before we begin i
want to remind everyone that this event
is interactive and we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click
send we'll answer as many questions as
we have time for
at the end of the presentation if you
have any trouble
seeing or hearing this presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by clicking on the
ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab
located at the top right of your
presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credit
i now present today's speaker dr omar
garner an associate clinical professor
section chief in the department of
pathology and laboratory medicine at
ucla health system for a complete
biography on our speaker please visit
the biography tab at the top
of your screen dr garner welcome you may
now begin your presentation
wonderful thank you so much i'd like to
thank
lab roots and dia soren for putting
together this talk on this
very timely and important topic
so as mentioned i am the section chief
of clinical microbiology at the ucla
health system
and today we're really going to dive in
and discuss testing strategies to help
manage
the copin 19 pandemic so for my
disclosures i get research funding
and honorarium from diasporin molecular
so our overall objective so after
today's talk my hope is that you will be
able to
identify current copin 19 testing status
and what might be next for laboratories
in the u.s
be able to define and fine-tune copin 19
diagnostic
algorithms for both the serological and
molecular approach and we hope to touch
on both
today and then discuss current testing
recommendations
and their implementation by one clinical
laboratory by my clinical laboratory i
don't mean to say in this talk that my
approach is the only approach
you know i think with something as
challenging as coping 19 all of our
laboratories have had to do everything
that we can
to be able to meet the need i just want
to present the ucla
approach as a potential model for how
we're looking at combating this disease
but i want to start with some background
you know i really think the story of
coronavirus and the story of coven 19
is a good place to begin so you know as
we know as laboratory professionals and
medical professionals on this call
pneumonia can be caused by many
different types of pathogens right there
are the classic bacterial pneumonia
pathogens
there are the fungal pneumonia pathogens
that affect the immune compromised
patient
and you know i think that we classically
think about a few
pneumonia pathogens that are viruses so
if you say
name me a virus that causes pneumonia i
think everyone's going to say influenza
a
and b and then i think there's another
group that are got definitely say
respiratory institutional virus and i
think in the immune competent patient
this really makes up the majority of
viruses that we know
to cause viral pneumonia but actually
the
list of viruses that can cause viral
pneumonia especially in the immune
compromised patient is pretty long and
so you can see here
it includes rhinovirus human
metanemovirus the four
pair influenza viruses boca virus and
then a long list but of course we're
going to focus today and the story today
is around coronaviruses and there are
human coronaviruses that can cause
viral pneumonia so looking at
coronaviruses as a group coronaviruses
are
enveloped non-segmented single-stranded
positive sense rna viruses
that are named after their corona or
crown-like projections
that you can see on these em pictures
and they correspond to the large
surface spike proteins that are found on
these viruses
now coronaviruses were first recognized
as an animal pathogen in the 30s
and human coronaviruses or hcovs
were first identified in the mid 1960s
so looking at the animal literature
these viruses infect respiratory and gi
systems or gastrointestinal systems
as well as occasionally affecting the
liver and neurological systems
human coronary viruses as a group are
mainly known to infect the upper
respiratory
and gi tract so this is a really nice
table of the known human coronaviruses
so there is
oc43 229e nl63 and hku1
and if you look overall sort of the
third fourth column in at the cell types
that are infected
these viruses mainly affect ciliated
airway epithelial cells so really it's
an
infection of the upper airway or upper
respiratory
tract so not surprisingly if you look in
the column the diseases that they cause
are mainly upper respiratory some of
them can definitely cause lower
respiratory tract infection
and just like the known animal
coronaviruses some of them can even
cause gi
disease now this leads us i think to
this
concept that we're going to talk about a
lot today which is spillover
spillover is when a pathogen moves from
one species
into another species and that's commonly
described as a
zoonotic infection all the coronaviruses
have this particular pathway and i want
to give a shout out
to one of my favorite books by david
quahlman it's called spillover and it
really
highlights in a very entertaining and
scientific way
the way that these viruses and pathogens
including hendra virus malaria
sars which we'll talk about today and
others have spilled over from an animal
population
into a human population uh on the
on the right side with the pictorial
that's there i really want to outline
this for coronaviruses you know the
purpose of doing this
is really kind of to demystify 19. i
feel like you know a lot of us were
potentially caught by surprise
that a coronavirus was able to spill
over into the human
population and then transmit around the
world
so actually this is a common mode of
infection
for coronaviruses so if we look on the
right side here
the natural host for nl63 which is the
human coronavirus that's seen now
circulating is the bats and the
intermediate host is typically an
organism that will become infected from
the natural host
and lead to an expansion of this virus
before it spills over into human beings
and then potentially transmits around
the world so it's unknown what the
intermediate host is for nl63 but if we
look
at let's say oc-43 this is another one
of our human coronaviruses
it didn't start out as a human virus
started out as a virus in rats
this spilled over into domestic cattle
from domestic cattle it moved into a
human population
and then spread around the globe as you
can see that that is the common story
for coping 19 as well
so it's not that all coronaviruses do
this but i think that we need to look at
covet 19
in the context of other coronaviruses
human coronaviruses
sars and mers to really understand that
this is a common pathway
for these particular viruses
so you know i think it brings us this
really important point
how does a spillover which is a
relatively common event anytime
animals interact with human beings you
can have pathogens that move from one to
another
become a global pandemic which we know
is a relatively uncommon event
i think this pictorial really does a
good job of describing this so you have
a set of viruses there
human coronavirus is one of them and
these viruses have a
high host plasticity what that means is
they can infect a large number of
species of animals so you can see all
these animals here potentially can
harbor this virus
then at that time humans come into
contact with these animals and then
there's spillover
so a human being becomes infected now
that does not mean
at that point that that virus can infect
other human beings so it doesn't mean
there will be human to human
transmission
but if there is human to human
transmission there can be an
amplification
of that particular virus and as we all
know we are a global
community i can get on a plane in los
angeles
and less than a day later i can be
almost anywhere in the world
that global spread of human beings
amplifies
human to human transmission allowing
viruses that are able to follow this
pathway
actually become global in their spread
this is exactly what we saw for copic 19
this is partially what we saw for sars
and this is actually what we originally
saw for our circulating human
coronaviruses as well
so what are some of the clinical
manifestations of the circulating human
coronaviruses
these cause the common cold they're
seasonal
the common cold is an upper respiratory
tract infection characterized by
rhinorrhea or runny nose
nasal congestion sore throat sneezing
something we've all had
symptoms are self-limiting and typically
peak on day three to four of illness
and less frequently as we discussed
before
these human coronaviruses can cause
lower respiratory tract disease this
includes bronchiolitis
croup and pneumonia but these are
primarily in infants and immune
compromised children
and if you look in laboratory medicine
so in my own lab we use a respiratory
pathogen panel that's actually able to
diagnose this because in our transplant
population
it's critically important to diagnose
patients with this disease
if you look at the overall epidemiology
human coronaviruses are found worldwide
so even though the initial spread was a
spillover
from an animal to a human population
they quickly spread around the globe
and they cause most disease in the
winter and spring months
exposure is common in early childhood
and if you look at serial positivity
for human coronaviruses approximately 90
of adults will be zero positive
uh droplet and direct contact spread are
the most likely common modes of
transmission
although there is some evidence of
indirect contact spread and aerosol
spread
similar to how we look at covid19 and
the incubation period for human
coronavirus is estimated to be about two
to five days
again as we're discussing these other
coronaviruses i want you to think about
how it relates or is potentially
different
to what we know what we know about
covid19
now i want to talk about some of the
recent animal spillovers for diseases
that were coronaviruses that had a
higher mortality and morbidity rate than
our human coronaviruses
so i'll start with sars so sars kovi
in 2002 was first recognized in china
and it caused the worldwide outbreak uh
the overall
case number was relatively low so 8 000
probable cases but the mortality rate
was actually very high
so 774 deaths were associated with
disease it leads to about a 10
mortality rate but since 2004 there have
not been any known cases of sars covi
infection
reported anywhere in the world other
transmission
similar to other coronaviruses you
started with an animal reservoir that
was found in bats
it appeared that the masked palm civet
was the intermediate animal reservoir
that caused transmission to human beings
and then we had human to humans spread
looking at clinical manifestations of
sars kov or what is known now as classic
sars because covet 19 is stars cov2
adults and adolescents experience fever
myalgia headache malaise and chills
followed by a non-productive cough and
dyspnia
generally five to seven days later
approximately 25 percent of infected
adults developed watery diarrhea now
this is something that appears as
distinctly different from covid19
right as we talked about those early
animal coronaviruses they could have gi
syndrome and with sars covi you saw more
of that than what you see with the copic
19.
gi syndrome with coping 19 is actually
much more rare
interestingly with sars kovi and this is
why the mortal mortality was so high
20 percent of patients developed
worsening respiratory distress
requiring intubation and ventilation we
know with covid19 20
of patients potentially get severe
disease and require hospitalization
but not this many actually require
intubation
the overall associated mortality was
approximately 10
and the case fatality rate in older
people so people older than 60 years
approached 50
this is also true of coping 19 is that
it appears to cause
more severe disease in people of
advanced age
and people that have comorbidities in
children with stars
the disease was less severe so no
infants or children died from sars covi
infection in the 2002 and 2003 outbreak
and infants and children younger than 12
years of age who developed
sars typically presented with only fever
cough and rhinorrhea
this is a similarity to copin 19 we find
less serious infection in children
so again part of the sort of
demystification process of coping 19
is that a lot of clues on the behavior
of coping 19 we can find from sars
and we can find from human coronaviruses
now of course this talk is geared
towards our group of laboratory medical
professionals so i think it's
interesting to look at
laboratory diagnosis for sars covi as
well or classic stars
so respiratory and stool specimens may
not be positive until the second week of
illness when symptoms and viral loads
peak
that is very interesting and that is a
distinction from copit19 where we're
finding out more and more that viral
loads may
peak in the pre-symptomatic window two
to three days before symptomatic
infection
whereas for sars cov they definitely
peaked much later on
this may be a clue as to why not so many
people got sars co-v and yet coven 19
infection is spreading around the world
here in this table found from a cdc
website you can see
for pcr detection there can be detection
in sputum
bronco aveli or lavage or bal
np swab op swab it was even found in
serum
and stool
so now we're going to transition away
from sars kovi or classic stars into
mers mers was the next sort of known
high morbidity high mortality animal
spillover event that led to some human
human transition
transmission from a coronavirus uh this
was discovered in 2014 but mers
transmission occurs even today
globally the world health organization
has been notified of 1100 laboratory
confirmed cases
of infection but including at least 422
related deaths so the mortality is even
higher
than sars only two patients in the
united states have ever tested positive
both where health care workers who lived
and worked in saudi arabia
and both traveled to the u.s from saudi
arabia where they believed to have been
infected
both were hospitalized but later
discharged after fully recovered
recent travelers from the arabian
peninsula who develop a fever
and symptoms of respiratory illness such
as cough or shortness of breath
within 14 days after traveling from
countries in or near the arabian
peninsula
may be considered for murs but an
important point for mers is it appears
that human to human
transmission is actually difficult and
most cases involve exposure to the
intermediate organism
which in this case is a camel so the
story is still the same you have
animal animal transmission from bats to
a camel and then potential
animal human transmission but very very
limited
human to human transmission and merge
it's really only been seen
in hospital settings so there's a wide
clinical spectrum associated with mers
infection
including asymptomatic infection all the
way up to acute
upper or lower respiratory tract illness
and then
rapidly progressive septic septic shock
multi-organ failure
and death the prodromal or early phase
disease is associated with fever chills
rigers headache and a non-productive
cough
similar to what we see with the other
coronavirus
most mers covi cases have been reported
in adults
although children and adults of all ages
have been infected and most
hospitalized mers cases have had chronic
comorbidities again
an establishment that's similar to sars
and establishments that's similar to
covid19
are this idea that people with chronic
comorbidities will have worse disease
and unfortunately among confirmed mers
kobe cases to date
the case fatality proportion has been as
high as 35
now interestingly i want to discuss
quickly lab diagnosis so
lab diagnosis for mers lower respiratory
tract specimens such as bal
sputum and tracheal aspirates contain
the highest
viral loads again this is something we
want to think about in relation to copin
19.
so for mers it's recommended that both
upper and lower respiratory tract
specimens collected whenever possible
we're going to discuss some ucla data
around covid19
for this recommendation later the world
health organization criteria for a
laboratory confirmed case
includes either a positive rtpcr result
for at least two different targets
on the mers genome or one positive rtpcr
result for a specific target
on the merge genome and an additional
different rtpcr
product sequence this is interesting
because it starts to open up the idea
that if you're going to
have a pcr that's specific for one of
these coronaviruses
that pcr needs to be multiple target for
all of us
running coping 19 tests within our
laboratories we know that almost
all very many of the copin 19 tests are
multiple target in order to appreciate
specificity
for serum antibody testing for mers
serum specimens should be collected
during the acute stage of disease
preferably the first week and again
after convalescence
three weeks later to be able to show
production of igg
so after a review of sars and mers
let's get to kobit 19. let's start to
talk about sars kovi ii
so this is the website that i'm
following on a regular basis to track
this
outbreak and you can really see the
global impact of this outbreak so as of
july
1st there were 10 million 538 thousand
confirmed cases and this is hitting
everywhere
across the globe so you can see there
really has been no country or no area
that has been untouched
by this particular disease sort of
speaking to the contagious nature
of this particular organism and then if
we
focus in on the united states you can
see that infection is unfortunately
rampant in all parts of the country and
so at that point
215 000 confirmed infections in new york
103
000 confirmed infections where i live in
los angeles
and you can see the entire spread across
our country so again you know i think
this leads us to this example
how did we get to this point how did we
get to this point and how is
lab diagnostics either affect our
getting to this point
or attempt to get us out of this how
does it spill over
an animal spill over become a pandemic
so for the next few slides i really want
to kind of discuss the early story
of covin 19 and how it relates
specifically
to testing so around the end of december
there were confirmed a cluster of
pneumonia cases of an unknown
cause and i want to emphasize that from
a diagnostic perspective
from a molecular diagnostic perspective
especially
we're in a completely different time in
2019 than we were in 2002 when sars hit
the capability of viral genome
sequencing of creating pcrs rapidly
is so much more advanced than it was now
which is why i think you saw this
accelerated timeline
in discovering what pathogen was the
cause of this
so with the cluster of cases it was
realized by early january there were 41
confirmed cases
seven severe one death and all of these
cases were negative
by the typical assays that are run in
clinical microbiology laboratory
right they were negative for flu as we
talked about viral flu is where you
would want to start they were negative
for rsv
they were negative for these tests these
respiratory pathogen tests
that cover a large range of cold viruses
they are even negative for stars and
mers so
january 8th the chinese cdc identified a
novel coronavirus in one of the patient
samples
and literally two days later which is
amazingly fast from a molecular
diagnostic perspective
the first genome was released and it was
understood that this was a novel
coronavirus
very closely related to sars so it was
named
severe acute respiratory syndrome or
sars coronavirus
ii initial cases were thought to be
linked to a
single seafood market where there was
potential animal spillover but i think
that it was very
quickly realized that there was human to
human
transmission going on and this was a
much larger story than just an
animal spillover event
so let's fast forward and i want to take
you through kind of how ucla
was looking at this so by january 15th
our emerging infectious disease group
which involves epidemiologists
infectious
disease clinicians and then of course
the microbiology laboratory
had started to get together to figure
out a way to potentially
screen patients for coping 19. so this
was just focus on
puis or persons under investigation
at this point these were definitions as
put out by the cdc
it included identification of people
based on travel history
to mainland china and symptoms of cough
shortness of breath and or fever some of
the main symptoms that were associated
with sars
interestingly we have one of the world's
largest airports in los angeles with lax
and we are at ucla one of the travel
hospitals to serve
lax so someone's going to be sick as a
traveler they can come into our hospital
so the idea is that
people would be screened at lax for
these symptoms if the travel was correct
and brought directly to ucla
now the diagnosis for copin 19 is not
symptomatic right
upper or even lower respiratory tract
infection
it's very difficult to say exactly what
the offending pathogen is just based on
symptoms
so this is where testing actually
becomes critical
in the importance of not only treating
patients but determining what's going on
with an outbreak
so at this time the only testing that
was available in the united states was
performed at the cdc
as everybody on this call is aware los
angeles is nowhere near
atlanta georgia so we had a five to six
day turnaround time with these
particular patients to be able to rule
out
this particular disease and as all of us
on this call can imagine
and our cdc colleagues can imagine the
cdc quickly became overwhelmed with the
volume of test requests if you imagine
the number of travelers that are coming
into the united states
from countries potentially that have
disease
the testing wasn't able to keep up with
that
so in february the idea was to try and
move the test
out of the cdc and into our state and
county public health laboratories
so we have one of you know in my opinion
the premier public health laboratories
across the country in la county
and our la county public health
laboratory was going to bring on
covet 19 testing this would be a huge
advantage for los angeles because it
would be able to reduce turnaround time
the cdc assay was distributed to state
and county public
health laboratories but unfortunately at
that time the assay failed validation
so there were three targets for that
assay all around the nuclear capsid gene
target n1 n2 and n3
you'll remember before we talked about
an expansion of targets with mers
in order to have appropriate specificity
all three needed to be positive for a
positive pcr
but the m3 target failed qc testing this
unfortunately delayed the ability for
public health laboratories to start
testing
eventually the cdc dropped that
particular target the necessity for that
target
and state and public health lab started
testing our laboratory in la county
brought up testing and started providing
testing for the community
unfortunately quickly they became
overwhelmed by the volume of test
requests so again
testing is unfortunately falling behind
the overall clinical need for the number
of patients
i'd like to give a shout out to dr hemer
ajata one of my former fellows at ucla
that now uh is a assistant director in
the public health laboratory at la
county
and is helping to lead and perform
testing there
okay so you know i think the question
that a lot of us had from the clinical
laboratories as we were watching this
happen is that when were we
going to be allowed to be able to
perform testing so on february 29th
clinical laboratories were allowed to
perform testing for covid19
what does that mean specifically i want
to piece this apart because even though
it opened up it actually didn't allow
very many laboratories to do the testing
so labs could perform either the fda
emergency use authorization
approved cdc test which is a cdc coven
19 pcr essay
the challenge with that specific test is
it required specialized equipment that
wasn't available in most clinical labs
highly trained cls with molecular
microbiology experience which is also
very difficult to find
and so most clinical labs couldn't bring
up that particular test
the other option presented by the fda
was to perform a laboratory develop test
for covid19
the challenge of developing your own
molecular tests is that it requires
specialized equipment not available in
most clinical labs
highly trained cls molecular
microbiology experience
and most clinical labs don't have this
either so unfortunately even though
there was an allowance from a regulatory
perspective to perform testing
the reality is that even by late
february most clinical laboratories
could not perform copic 19 pcr testing
now fortunately for us at ucla we had
all the component pieces necessary
to perform the cdc test in-house and so
by march 10th we actually brought up the
cdc copin 19rt pcr test
looking specifically at that test it's
now a two target test
as we talked about for the n1n2 gene
just some details from a lab medicine
perspective
uh the crossing threshold or ct value
cutoff for the
targets is 40. the result is an
inconclusive if only one of two targets
is positive and i'm going to show you
some data later
as to whether we think early on those
were false positives or weak positives
and of course the assay is invalid if
the encoding control fails
and the throughput on this particular
assay is not very high
so let's walk through that for because
we all know that we're being asked to
perform
you know up to thousands of tests a day
for this particular test it required
certain extraction equipment that got
expanded over time but of course there
was reagent shortage
the extraction takes a couple hours and
then the pcr
setup required three wells per patient a
well for each individual target
so if you're running a 96 well plate you
know at max you could do 30 samples but
if you remember early on
the suggestion was to take a
nasopharyngeal separate from an
oropharyngeal
so now you have to use two so that's six
wells per patient
so now overall in a run that can take up
to eight hours you can do very very few
patients overall
and this was some of the very early
constraints for us expanding testing to
the population
so you know i think we were all sort of
waiting as the fda was giving
eua authorization for other tests so
that
more and more clinical labs could expand
so here you can see
february 4th the cdc test became eua
approved again not approved for clinical
labs to run
but approved early on that wasn't until
the 29th
other laboratories submitted laboratory
developed tests like wadsworth
lab core quest diagnostics and then what
we started to see
was tests come on the market being
available for clinical laboratories
so by mid-march you started to see
companies like thermal fissure
companies like abbott molecular
companies like
deosorin denmark cepheid have products
come on the market that could be then
run in the clinical labs
the advantage of this and again the
partnership between
molecular diagnostic companies and
clinical laboratories is essential
for being able to bring up this type of
testing is it allowed us to
expand testing at ucla
so we were able to bring on the diastore
molecular rt-pcr test this is the
simplexa kovid19 direct kit
the targets on the virus are a little
bit different so this looks at the s
gene and the open reading frame one gene
uh the
ct value cut off is 40. interestingly
with this assay you only needed one
target to be positive to call a sample
positive i'll show you some data
a little bit later on um we feel that
one target ends up being
reasonably appropriate from a
specificity perspective
to call positive value um
for all of these tests reagent
allocation was
a was an issue right i think that all of
us
in clinical labs either doing testing or
running labs have seen that
we can't necessarily get as much reagent
as we could possibly run
because of the overall need it's
difficult for companies to keep up
so we were on a 350 test a day reagent
allocation which i think put us in one
of the more
fortunate situations very early on
acceptable specimens for this was
nasopharyngeal swabs and nasal swabs and
then this has grown now to include bals
and it's really a medium throughput
system so depending on how many of these
tests that you have
that you can run continuously the test
is relatively fast
runtime itself is only 90 minutes
compared to some other system where you
have to do
extraction off put extraction and run
pcr
now again my hospital system continued
to ask us to meet the clinical need
by running more and more testing so we
looked at a third system to bring in and
i think you've seen this across the
board at a lot of clinical laboratories
we're all running multiple systems
specifically to be able to run covet 19
testing
so for the thermo fisher tac path assay
for coping 19
which we also perform we are running
it's an n
gene s gene orf one targeted system
and the inconclusives in this setting is
one out of three positive is
inconclusive
if it's two out of the other three gene
targets then that's considered a
positive
our throughput in this particular assay
is expanding up to about
a thousand tests per day and the
acceptable specimens on this is
nasopharyngeal swab
and bal so this is really our high
throughput system
we're running it on the kingfisher for
extraction
the pcr setup is multiplex so you only
need one well per patient
and then we're using the abi 7500 very
similar to the cdc assay
to perform testing so you know i think
a lot of us are in an unusual scenario
as discussed before where
we have a lot of different tests for
these same
specific analytes right if you look
across the board at most clint micro
labs
you aren't running let's say three
different tests for hiv viral load
the reason you don't do that is tests
have different sensitivities and
specificities
and you don't want to end up having kind
of a good test versus a not so good test
and triaging patients so an important
analysis for us
in thinking about testing for kova 19
pcr
is how are our tests performing overall
and so this really is an analysis of
about 10 000 test results
that we did a few months ago comparing
three of our assays
comparing the cdc rt pcr assay on the
left
the diastore and symplexa direct assay
in the middle
and the tac tacpath or thermofisher
assay on the right
you can see in the graph we divided them
up by number of specimens and then
really started to look at overall
ct values for our patients are we seeing
ct values skew depending on
the gene targets right this is really
important because
if one assay looks at the s gene and one
assay looks at the end gene
potentially they don't have the same
level of sensitivity
for figuring out whether the virus is
there so one good thing that came from
our analysis is we learned overall it
looks like sort of the spread of
patients
that have been tested there's an
equivalent spread of strong positive
medium positive and weak positive
samples as assessed by ct value
in addition if you look at our
positivity rates overall we have about a
seven percent positivity rate on the cdc
test six percent on the diasoren test
simplexa and about four percent on our
thermal fissure
this made sense to us that even though
they weren't the same our thermal
fissure test is mainly an outpatient
test
whereas our inpatient really drives
towards the deosorin test so we see a
little bit higher
uh positivity rate and then if we look
overall at either
inconclusive or invalids the numbers end
up being
uh low so that's good meaning we're not
having to repeat testing very much
so you know i think around pcr tests one
of the more common
questions that i receive as a clinical
lab director
is is this test sensitive right my
physicians call
lots of group call they want to know and
one of the reasons is because there were
some early publications
came out i focus on this one in jama
that suggested that nasal swabs
nasopharyngeal swabs
actually had a very low percent
positivity
or sensitivity versus something like a
lower respiratory tract specimen like a
bal
so how do we answer this or how do we
even analyze this
in the laboratory no i think that one
way of looking at sensitivity is
analytical sensitivity
analytical sensitivity is really this
measure of how
good is your pcr essay how
few viral copies can you recognize and
when we do some analytical sensitivity
measurements on some of our assays we
find our assays are
i would call them exquisitely sensitive
they can be sensitive all the way down
to 100 copies of virus per ml
the way that i talk to my physicians
about this is if there is virus in the
sample
our assay is going to find it but the
real question and this is
question of clinical sensitivity is is
there any virus in the sample or how
likely is a negative to be a false
negative
and for clinical sensitivity there's a
whole lot more parameters
that go into understanding that this
includes specimen type
is it a nasopharyngeal swab is it an
oral pharyngeal swab
is it saliva is it mid-terminate or
anterior nares
all of those things depend on how much
virus can be collected
in addition is it a good nasopharyngeal
swab right it was a called
nasopharyngeal but the collector didn't
go in as far as they could have
and then additionally stage of illness
ends up being critically important and i
think we're still learning this from
this disease
where is the virus at what time so if
someone's within the first two to three
days of symptoms
what's the best specimen to collect
let's say someone's having severe
disease
what's the best specimen to collect so
in that sort of thing we all want to be
able to
understand overall these comments that
say
i heard your pcr test only has a 63
sensitivity so what we really want to
determine at ucla is how do we actually
estimate clinical sensitivity how do we
take the results that we have
to answer this question about all the
variabilities that can come in
and figure out do we have a test that's
really only 60
sensitive when we're doing
nasopharyngeal swaps so
in that setting we took this idea that a
false negative patient
is a patient with an initial negative
pcr test that has subsequent testing
at any time and it's positive and again
this is a symptomatic analysis
where a true negative patient would be a
patient with an initial negative pcr
test but the results remain negative for
all
subsequent testing so dividing up we
actually have a substantial amount of
repeat testing that goes on at ucla for
nasopharyngeal swaps
this is to our advantage in being able
to understand clinical sensitivity
so if you look at the first table below
811
patients ended up having a initial
negative result and had repeat tests
on that negative and of those 811 795
were true negatives meaning the second
test ended up being
negative as well where only 16 ended up
having a positive test
after that this is important because it
really gives an understanding of
clinical sensitivity
around 98 percent for a first
time nasal pharyngeal swab that's a
negative
in a symptomatic patient so this really
helped to sort of allay some of the
fears around clinical sensitivity
in our system interestingly we also
wanted to do this analysis to see there
is
if there was variability amongst the
three pcr assays
and as you can see on the table below if
you break up the initial negative
and then subsequent testing you see that
they all
end up having a sensitivity that is
around
98 so you know this equates to the
sensitivity that we see for a lot of our
assays and really sort of i think
helps with an understanding or at least
an argument against
when people push and say oh the
nasopharyngeal test does not have good
sensitivity now
we don't know in an asymptomatic
population i have to emphasize that this
is symptomatic data
to be able to say that about a
first-time negative
nasopharyngeal swab the same study would
need to be
repeated in the asymptomatic population
but this would be challenging because
the positivity rates in those
populations are very low
so the next question that came up you
know and i think we addressed this a
little bit earlier is which specimen
type is most sensitive that early jama
paper suggested that lower respiratory
tract
testing may be most important and you
know this is what we saw with sars if
you remember back to the lab diagnostics
for sars
it was really lower respiratory tract
testing that had the highest yield
so what do we see for coping 19 so we
picked apart
our specimens coming in of course we're
doing lower respiratory versus upper
respiratory
and i want to point out a few things so
first if you look at bal
20 positive out of 284 collected that's
a 7
positivity rate versus our
nasopharyngeal
we're only at a 3.2 positivity rate
you know i think on first glance that
may imply that bal
is in fact a more sensitive specimen
source
for severely treated patients but when
we pick these data apart
what we find is that all lower
respiratory tract positive patients at
ucla
have also had a preceding positive
upper respiratory tract sample so in
that setting our data we're not finding
patients who are upper respiratory tract
negative or np swab negative
but lower respiratory tract positives
when we find it in the lower we also
find it in the upper
but we know this is not the experience
at all centers
so what we tell our clinicians
especially in the severe side
is we endorse sending us both
send us an upper respiratory send us a
lower respiratory
we do feel that the nasopharyngeal is
the best collection
but there is some solid data out there
to suggest in the symptomatic patient
and again i have to emphasize here i'm
only talking about the symptomatic
patient in the symptomatic patient
other sources may also be appropriate
mid-terminate
oral pharyngeal potentially saliva i
don't think we know anything in the ac
asymptomatic but in the symptomatic you
know i think these patients
have a very they have a high amount of
virus you know we can sort of see this
from the ct values
not a direct comparison like viral load
but we see
increase decreased ct values which means
increased amount of virus
in patients who are symptomatic
so the next question i really want to
address is the inconclusive results
you know i think we started this out by
saying multi-target may be necessary for
specificity
but what does it mean if only one target
is positive
on these tests where if one target is
positive it's an inconclusive
so this is an analysis of symptomatic
patients
run on the cdc test early on in disease
so this was in march for us
so we had six patients that had
inconclusive results
and we wanted to do a deep dive on the
likelihood of those patients either
being true positive
or false positive and so what we found
across the board and you can see the
data here the specimen date the specimen
type
whether there was a first test or a
repeat test and which target was
positive
n1 or n2 as we did an analysis that
included
exposure repeat testing what we found is
that
in our opinion five out of these six
were most
likely positives true positives and the
inconclusive represented a weak positive
result
whereas one out of the six really looked
more like a false positive there wasn't
any other data to suggest and on
follow-up testing
they were always negative so what does
this overall mean
you know i'm not quite sure what this
overall means i think that it means that
there are certain settings that
inconclusive is going to be a weak
positive
and because these were symptomatic
patients you know i think a lot of this
is about your pre-test
probability i think in a very
symptomatic patient the pre-test
probability is high for covid
an inconclusive result could definitely
be a weak positive
whereas now when there's more
asymptomatic testing going on we need to
do a re-analysis of our inconclusives
because potentially we would see the
opposite of this and maybe they're more
likely false positives when you're
testing people
who really are asymptomatic and do not
have a high likelihood of covid
so again we haven't made any broad
sweeping statements but i do think it's
interesting to analyze
inconclusive results overall
now i want to share some of our total
data from ucla
so um if you look overall from our
inpatient perspective we've had a
about a 1.4 positivity rate outpatient
2.4 percent ed 4.2 percent
uh and total we've come up about a 2.6
the challenge of looking overall at
positivity though is it really is about
who you're testing
so at ucla we're fortunate enough to
have enough testing capability in my
laboratory
to not only perform symptomatic testing
but to perform asymptomatic
screening on patients that are coming in
for procedures
that could be at high risk if they ended
up having the infection
to the people performing those
procedures to our physicians to our
techs
to anyone involved in a patient care
setting when you start to screen a large
amount of asymptomatic patients
by definition it's going to bring down
your overall percent positivity
so maybe that's not the best marker of
what's going on with symptomatic disease
if you can see over time though early on
in march in early march we peaked at a
percent positivity of 16 percent
low volume being tested but all of them
being potentially symptomatic
and has gone down over time but what you
can see is in late june and early july
as sort of you're seeing with the rest
of the country we are starting to bump
back up
in positivity rate also our overall
number of positives are coming up as
well
looking at testing volumes this has been
one of the sort of extreme
changes seen in a microbiology
laboratory and i really want to thank
all the laboratory professionals that
are on this call for all of the work
that we're doing
to fight coven 19. this is the
representation
at ucla you can see on march 9th we
started doing zero cases
and per day and following the blue line
we've peaked now so this
goes out to 6 29 we had a day last week
where we did 1200
in a day 1200 pcr tests in a single day
and so
really it takes a heroic effort
across the country by our laboratory
testing professionals to be able to pull
this off
in support of fighting this pandemic so
this is our example that ucla
and i know all labs have been pushing to
be able to meet their need
so overall just to show what's going on
at ucla specifically we've tested at
that point
38 000 patients now we're up above 42
000
and our number positive patients that
are there
so i want to leave pcr now and spend a
few slides talking about serology before
we end
so the clinical use of covid19 serology
is
is interesting you know i think it's a
test where we have a result that we
don't exactly know what to do with
at this point so it's unclear if
antibodies are protective or
neutralizing and a lot of the tests
have different antigen targets for
antibodies and so
it's hard to know exactly what is being
measured but we do know that antibodies
serology
plus aggressive pcr are probably our
best strategies
for continued to fighting this
particular infection
and there's some data to suggest that
the median time to seroconversion
may be around 14 days is probably later
probably 21 to 28 days
as a median but we also know overall
that um every single individual antibody
test doesn't behave the same
so originally there were a lot of
non-fda reviewed tests there are
point-of-care tests
target choice ends up being very
important and target choice is going to
vary amongst the tests
so the landscape is very dynamic from a
serology perspective i would say the
landscape is also very dynamic from a
pcr perspective
but overall almost all of the rtpcr
assays
no matter what their targets were have
behaved very similarly
this sort of analysis is not fully done
from a serology perspective
so i want to present to you what we're
doing at ucla we use the in-house
we in-house we use the diastore and
copin 19 igg
chemiluminescent immune assay the
antibody target is the spike protein
and data from the package insert shows a
97.6 percent sensitivity in patients
that are six days
past pcr positivity again you may not be
pcr tested right away so you're
estimating this is reaching that 21 to
28 day window post infection
as up to 99 sensitive 14 days past pcr
positivity and importantly has a 99.3
specificity specificity is going to be
critically important because
false positives on the serology test may
give people a sense of protection
if antibodies mean you're immune and we
still don't know that yet
but if they do in the case of a positive
test result
uh you know we can have with the
instruments that we have the reagent
allocation and
and the need was there a potential 3000
test per day
capacity and this is a similar platform
we run other serology tests on
so we're averaging about 200 tests a day
on the weekdays
and we're running about a six percent
overall rate so so what does that mean
so i think it's important as we close
out here to do a little bit of
lab medicine general analysis and an
understanding
of positive predictive value and
sensitivity and specificity
so sensitivity and specificity is really
the chance of your test
giving a false negative and false
positive outside of the context of
prevalence
of disease but in really to understand
positive predictive value or negative
predictive value meaning the likelihood
of a true positive
versus a false positive that's positive
predicted value or likelihood of a true
negative
versus false negative you have to
include the prevalence of disease
in a society so this is a table that
represents some of the
uh prevalence tables that would be
associated with a test
with a 97 sensitivity and 99.3
specificity so let's go to the areas
where let's say prevalence is 20
the prevalence of a disease is 20
meaning
out of the people that you're testing 20
of them are potentially
positive the positive predictive value
is high meaning that if you get a
positive you have a 96
chance that that positive is a true
positive but if you go to the other
extreme end and the prevalence is only
one percent and again
the specificity of this test is very
high it's 99.3 percent
the prevalence or amount of disease
drives down the positive predictive
value
so ultimately you only have a 50
positive predictive value if you get a
positive
so the prevalence of disease is low in
society and somebody gets a serology
test that's positive there's only a 50
50 shot
that that's a true positive versus a
false positive this is why it's very
difficult right now to suggest that
anybody
get a serology test if they fit in this
one percent prevalence category
we really should be using our serology
tests for
places that have a higher prevalence so
the question is then
who has a higher prevalence and who
should be tested
so this is really our decision at ucla i
think other places they'll come to other
decisions
but again this is what we're suggesting
in order to increase the prevalence or
likelihood that someone has had coveted
19 we believe serology testing could be
used in the setting of suspected prior
infection
that was not tested by pcr as we covered
on this
a lot of people potentially had disease
in their weapon pcr testing available
close contacts of high risk patients who
may have been exposed to the virus
healthcare workers and first responders
this represents a group that has a
potential much higher prevalence than
the community at large
patients residing in congregate settings
that may have been exposed to or
infected with a virus in the past
but who are not actively infected with
the virus
these are settings where you're seeing
outbreaks like nursing home facilities
like jails where there's potentially a
high concentration
of infected individuals potentially
patients who are scheduled for a
procedure
or surgery you may be able to use
serology to avoid repeat
pcr testing and then if immunity is
something that's correlated with
antibody testing
and then in the setting of potential
plasma donation uh
for convalescent therapy i think that
this ends up being one of the most
straightforward uses
of the serology test where should it not
be used and i think this is critically
important
piece fluorology testing for igg which
are the approved serology test should
not be used to diagnose acute coping
and then generally because igg doesn't
come up that early and then generally it
should not be used for testing low risk
community patients
with no suspicion of recent infection
who may simply be curious or want to
know if they were infected
because again we fall into the
prevalence of having a poor predictive
value even if you have
a very good test so i hope
over the course of this lecture you were
able to get an idea
on how pcr and serology testing is being
used at ucla
you know i think it's an ever-changing
environment as we learn more and more
about immunity
we may learn better on how to use our
serology tests
as we learn more and more about sort of
the earlier phases of disease
and asymptomatic carriers we can better
use
our pcr tests but i will say that as lab
medicine professionals we have never
been more in the forefront
so la times has featured our laboratory
at ucla
here our senior specialist brian boland
was featured
uh an article uc has a solution to the
national storage of coronavirus testing
do it in-house in addition other
members of my laboratory were
highlighted and so you know i think that
again
as laboratory medical professionals
we've always known that our work is
critical to patient care but now i think
it's being seen across the country
how critical it is and i want to thank
everybody working in a laboratory
setting
helping to fight cloven 19 or perform
any level
of laboratory testing i want to finish
with my acknowledgement slide
this is part of my virology group
this group of techs and staff has been
working
overtime volunteering on the weekends
to provide coping 19 testing for our
patients and our hospital system i want
to thank all of them
i want to thank dr sean yang our
associate director
and dr sarah dry my department chair
for some of the slides that i used and
then allison nomura
for providing a lot of the data analysis
for this particular talk
i want to thank you all for your time
and i'm happy to take any questions
and thank you dr garner for that
informative presentation
we will now start the live q a portion
of the webinar
and if you have any questions you'd like
to ask please do so now just
click on that ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen
and we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
so let's get started we have quite a few
questions
that have already come in from our live
audience
dr garner can you provide your thoughts
on the cdc recommendation for the
differential
diagnosis of flu and covid19 in the
upcoming flu season yeah absolutely you
know that's a great question i think
diagnostics are going to play a very
important role for the upcoming flu
season so you know i think that it's
important to recognize
that while there may be small
differences between
covid19 infection and fluid infection
from a symptom perspective
many of the symptoms are shared and i
think it's going to be very very
difficult for
our physician colleagues our healthcare
practitioner colleagues
to be able to differentiate a flu case
from a cobit 19 case
and so while there's going to be the
expectation we should have a lot of
those
you know it's really going to be on
diagnostic manufacturers and then
clinical laboratories
to bring in testing algorithms to
differentiate these two
as quickly as possible because we
definitely expect
whether it's you're going to describe it
as a second wave or a third wave we
definitely expect a large number of
copic 19 cases
coupled with a large number of influenza
cases and they're going to be very
difficult to differentiate from a
symptoms perspective
thank you for that and do you envision
in the future the need to have
assays with indications for screening of
all individuals not just suspected
um so that we can have an accurate
infection control
yeah that is also sort of the question
of the hour
right i think that as a country we're
getting a better hold
of doing symptomatic and suspected
testing we're not where we need to be
and i've definitely been in conversation
with areas of the country where there is
still
not nearly enough testing for
symptomatic and suspected patients
but having sort of trying to approach
that threshold i think we will continue
to make progress but it really doesn't
tell us
about asymptomatic transmission of this
particular disease which we know is very
important
so some level of large-scale
asymptomatic surveillance screening is
going to occur
but it needs to occur but it needs to
occur sort of outside
of the limited reagent and people
constraints of our clinical laboratories
right because whatever test it's going
to be that's going to let's say survey
10 000 people on a weekly basis that's
going to be part of
how we get back to work you know we're
going to have to come up with
an assist with very new diagnostics and
new ways of thinking about diagnostics
so for example potentially some of these
easier collection sources like
that's where saliva can fit in that may
be where sort of large scale
sequencing assays can fit in to be able
to
supplement our testing of suspected
and um symptomatic patients
thank you dr garner and i want to thank
our audience for these very
thought-provoking questions
dr garner what are your thoughts on when
the infection rate may come
down in the u.s or will we have to live
with covid19 in the foreseeable future
well you know i think we've learned a
lot over this past
sort of few weeks in july that
any sort of expectation that we're going
to see infection rates go down
we are a long way away from and there
are hot spots
jumping up all over the country and you
know i think that it's it's very very
difficult to control this particular
infection
and you know i think widespread use of
some of the policies that we know
work like masking like paying attention
to social distancing
you know these are just things that
we've had trouble adopting
as a nation and taking on to be able to
protect each other
so you know as long as we're not able to
sort of make headway that way i think we
can continue to expect
what's going on and we can continue to
expect
this level of infection until we have a
vaccine you know i wish i could be more
optimistic about that but that just
doesn't appear to be where we are
right now as a country but i'm hopeful
well not optimistic i'm definitely
hopeful that we can bring down the
overall infection rate but it is going
to take
people you know their own individual
behaviors is what
is how we fight this absolutely
and when is a lower respiratory sample
essential for cobit 19 testing for
example
bal and tibutan yeah you know i think
that
whether it's going to be bal or tracheal
aspirates or sputum or any of these
things
it's really about severe disease in the
hospital you know i think our experience
at
ucla is that we do feel a nasopharyngeal
may be appropriate in all stages of
disease
but you could i've seen scenarios i've
read case studies where upper
respiratory tract
infection was negative yet lower
respiratory there was virus there for
diagnosis so in that setting
i do think that for the hospitalized
patient
it is appropriate to either order both
an
upper and a lower or if the upper is
negative and you know the clinician
really feels that coven 19 is high on
the differential
by all means sort of collect a lower
respiratory specimen and send it to the
laboratory
thank you dr garner we have time for a
few more questions
and i just want to remind our audience
that any question is not answered
um right now will be answered via email
mr garner can you provide your thoughts
on the cdc
recommendation for orthogonal testing in
serology
yeah you know i think this is a very
interesting recommendation by the cdc
and may end up being very important so
the concept of orthogonal testing is
really
testing by one antibody test that has
one target and then testing by a
different antibody test
that has a separate target and this
really gets that specificity so if you
have a
test that has a spike protein target you
recognize that antibody
and you have a test that has a nuclear
capture protein target
if you run both and they're both
positive the likelihood of that being a
true
positive becomes higher so right we
talked about prevalence and false
positivity
and positive predictive value so i
believe that's what
being thought of there you know i think
that until we sort of know whether or
not
antibody and antibody testing positivity
is related to immunity
we'll get closer to that level of
recommendation but i do think it's
interesting
to take a two-target approach to
increase
the positive predictive value
and do you see value in identifying or
measuring
igm response and idg response so
sterology
testing as opposed to just a total
measurement value
yeah that is also a question that i
don't think we have enough data on so
most of the tests that are available now
are either total or igg total meaning
any antibody that's there mostly igg and
igm
and just igg i think the challenge of
igm
itself is that you know i think we know
in lab medicine igm
tends to be a little bit more
cross-reactive
than igg you know and we're already sort
of battling this challenge of positive
predictive value and so
if you bring on an antibody test that
may even be a little bit more
cross-reactive
are we diagnosing disease and then
really this concept of can igm be used
to diagnose acute disease well you know
i think that pcr
does a good job of diagnosing acute
disease
you can imagine a scenario igm may be
able to supplement that
but i think the challenge is if there's
an igm test
that is presented as an acute disease
test it'll attempt to replace
pcr not supplement pcr and i think that
that's dangerous because
igm will come up later than
pcr positivity
thank you for that and we have time for
one more question this one's about the
fda
europe now has serology tests that
quantify
mutualizing antibodies to sars code
ii should fda consider making these
available in the u.s and why
um so my answer to that is yes i do
think that if we have a neutralizing
antibody
test that's easy to perform so not a
plaque reduction neutralization assay
itself
but a neutralizing antibody claim on
some of our antibody tests it may do
better at predicting immunity
if neutralizing antibody is what's
conveying immunity
now that may be an oversimplification of
the immune system right
potentially t cell driven immunity may
be what's important for this particular
disease
so the correlation of neutralizing
antibody with immunity may not be there
but to me
the more sort of validated tests that we
have available
in our repertoire to use against this
disease the better we'll be able to
understand that
so you know widespread availability of a
neutralizing antibody test
around allows us to run clinical studies
allows us to
better analyze whether immunity is held
there and what that means for a person
who's serologically positive
so i'm a fan you know i hope the fda
takes a serious look at those assays
and if they are high enough quality for
patient testing in the united states i
would hope that they would move
quickly to be able to approve that
dr garner thank you for a presentation
would you like to provide any final
comments for our audience before we
finish today
i would just like to of course thank lab
roots and diastole for putting this on
but mostly i want to thank every single
laboratory professional that is
listening to this particular talk your
work has been
essential in our fight against this
particular disease
and you know i think you can see i mean
honestly we get calls all the time from
our nurses from our positions
just thanking our laboratory for making
testing available for this
so all the work that you're doing you
know you really it is well appreciated
to fight this pandemic so i want to
thank you all and then i also want to
emphasize
you know please please please wear your
masks
wear your masks when you're at work
where are your masks when you're outside
of work
let's do everything that we can to be
able to fight this particular disease
thank you again dr garner for your time
today for your important research
i'd also like to thank lavrutz and our
sponsor diazorn for
underwriting today's educational webcast
and before we go i want to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed
by the speaker via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration
and lab routes will alert you via email
when this webinar is available for
replay
so we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's
live event until next time be safe
take care bye